- Hi everyone, Sal Khan here
for our daily homeroom.
For those of y'all who are new to this,
Khan Academy, we are
not-for-profit with a mission
of providing a free world-class education
for anyone, anywhere.
And when we saw the mass school closures,
not just in the United States,
but around the world,
there's now over 1.4 billion
students around the world
who normally would go
to school, who aren't.
We realized that above and beyond
the resources that Khan Academy
has been creating for years,
and offering for free
for teachers, students and parents,
for students inside of classrooms
and outside of classrooms
around the world,
that it's our duty to step up and do more.
So we've been doing things like
parent and teacher webinars,
we've been publishing things
like the daily schedules
for different age groups,
that some of y'all might be familiar with.
And we are also doing this livestream,
and it's a way to stay connected
in this time of social distancing.
It's a way
to answer any questions
that you might have,
and it's also a way to have
interesting conversations
that are related to
what's going on around us.
It could be related to education,
or it could be related to
just the broader environment.
I do wanna say a few thank you's.
As I mentioned, we're a not-for-profit.
We're funded with philanthropic donations.
Even before the COVID crisis
we were running at a deficit.
And now our traffic on Khan
Academy is about two and a half,
it looks like, I looked this morning,
it's about 2.8 what it normally is.
And so that only increases our cost.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about helping us out,
khanacademy.org/donate.
And I wanna give a special thanks
to several corporations who stepped up
over the last couple of
weeks in record time,
to help us with this COVID response.
These include folks like Bank of America,
which was the first to step up.
And shortly thereafter, AT&T,
Google.org and NORVATIS.
And that's above and beyond
many of the foundations
and philanthropists and
corporations like AMGEN,
that have funded Khan
Academy through the years.
And as much as that funding helps,
I do wanna emphasize
that we still need more.
We're still operating at
a significant deficit.
So funding at any level helps.
Over the weekend I put
a video out on YouTube,
essentially just doing what I just did,
saying that we,
someone put that video onto Reddit,
and over the weekend it helped
raise us a lot of money.
So thank you for doing that.
That definitely spread the word.
But I also wanna emphasize that
we are still running at a deficit
and depleting our reserves
in order to do what we're doing.
So what we're gonna do today, like always,
whether you're watching
this on YouTube, Facebook,
or some other social media channel.
This is changing day by day.
We're getting fancier every day.
But start posting questions.
I have access to some of them,
and then some of our team members are
looking at those questions,
and they're putting it up
on a doc that I can read.
But we have a special guest today.
Our special guest today is a teacher
by the name of Tim Vandenberg,
who teaches sixth grade students
in Hesperian, California.
And I think there's a couple
of really interesting,
or many interesting things
to talk to Tim about.
But when you think about the questions,
you can ask questions for me.
But also, you can pose questions,
whether you're a teacher,
parent or student,
from a really impressive teacher
that'll help us think
about how Khan Academy
can be used in the classroom
for maximum impact,
but also maybe some ways to think about
how it could be used at
home during the closures.
So Tim, thanks for joining us.
- Hi, Sal.
- And I actually, I was watching
this documentary about Monopoly, recently.
And beyond being a superstar teacher,
you are also, what was it,
number two in the country in Monopoly?
- At the last US Championships,
I placed second place.
So they say that puts me at
rank number two in the country.
So it was a lot of fun.
- You're such a sucker, Tim (laughs)
(Tim laughs)
- My sixth graders
helped train me, so yeah.
- Oh, okay
So we might have a few
champions in that group too.
So maybe,
a good place to start,
- Yes.
You know, tell us tell
everybody how you've,
you know, pre-COVID crisis,
how you were using Khan
Academy in your classroom?
The types of students that
you've been trying to help out,
where were they before?
And then what have you seen since?
- Well, with Khan Academy,
and so what I decided is,
I'm gonna make my sixth graders go back
to the early grade levels,
do early math, arithmetic,
the lower grade levels,
(machine beeps)
on Khan Academy,
to master and fill in the
holes like you've described
so well on your many videos,
that I encourage people to go watch.
And by having them go back and review,
and fill in those gaps,
these very low disadvantaged,
highly diverse kids, who were basically
failing their lower grade skills
on the state test for California.
They ended up absolutely doing fantastic
on their state test results
over the last three years,
and it would have been
four years in a row,
but California decided
not to have state testing this year
due to the emergency health situation.
But we have a data chart I can show
the absolutely amazing results
using mastery learning,
I think your team is gonna post that up.
So on the left hand side you can see,
on how these kids did in fifth grade
compared to their California,
county and district peers.
And this is compared to
the green line on top,
that is a passing score in fifth grade,
over to a passing score in
sixth grade, on the right.
And you see my kids are
basically the average kid
in California and the county and district,
and my class are very
far below grade level.
But using the mastery learning model
that is so powerful and
easy to do on Khan Academy,
my kids average growing
95 points last year,
and pretty much the
same the last two years
before that as well.
Compare that to the
average kid in California,
went up just over one point.
One point of growth,
and that's the best scores I can find
over the last three years in California,
was two years ago.
That's almost 95 times the growth
of the average kid in California.
That doesn't mean every kid,
but that's the average.
- And just to make sure,
and just to make sure
I understand this chart,
what this shows is,
on the left hand side,
the left point is,
performance on the fifth grade state test.
- And then,
on the right data dot,
- Yeah.
- the performance of sixth grade.
So a student who just tracks
that green line on the left,
that means they're right at
grade level for fifth grade.
And then a year later,
they're right at sixth
grade for sixth grade.
So that would be what
essentially the standards,
or the assessments expect of students,
essentially you get a year
of learning in a year.
And it looks like California on average,
starts fifth grade well below grade level,
and then starts sixth
grade well below grade,
or starts the year well below grade level
and then ends the year
well below grade level,
but there's about a grade level of growth.
Your students,
- Yeah,
- and I think if I read
some of your background,
90% of them were below grade level
and what you're looking at,
we're looking at
- Right.
- is the average,
but significantly below grade level,
you're talking you know,
high needs student body,
100% free and reduced lunch.
But over the course of the year,
almost all of them being significantly
below grade level,
to almost all of them being significantly
above grade level, after a year.
- Exactly.
And this is for,
teachers might understand this,
parents may not quite grasp this.
But this is absolutely amazing growth,
and this is real.
And this is not teaching to the test,
this is lives changed.
These kids now believe that
they can learn math and master math,
all thanks to mastery learning
model on Khan Academy.
Because they actually want
- Something I want
to make sure,
- to be filling those out,
- So explain that, explain how those gaps
are actually filled in.
What's interesting is,
these are sixth grade students,
and you're starting them off
many times at early learning,
which is kindergarten first,
second grade arithmetic type content.
And many folks could say wait,
if they're gonna go
all the way back there,
how can they ever get
to grade level content,
much less get ahead of grade level?
- Right, so during the school year
while still simultaneously teaching
and mastering the sixth grade skills,
which is very hard for them,
because they don't have the foundations,
we also, I require them to go back
and do the course challenges
and the unit tests
for all of the lower grade levels.
So that math actually starts
to make sense to them,
so that they truly become
math masters and champions,
and actually start believing that this
is something they can do.
And the majority of them I graduate
and send them off to honors class,
or above grade level classes
in junior high because of this.
- And so this is really
a bit of an idea of,
as you can say, even
going slowly or go fast.
We talked a lot about
it here at Khan Academy
is that in a traditional model,
let's say a student
gets an 80% on you know,
their multiplication tables,
then the next year when
they're learning division,
they're building it on a weak
foundation of multiplication.
When you get to algebra,
and there's a decimal,
if you've only got 70% in
fifth grade on decimals,
now you're building on a weak foundation.
And that might be or that arguably is,
the reason why so many
people struggle in math,
and you see the data gets worse and worse,
the farther you get advanced,
because those gaps come debilitating.
But what you've been able
to do is use Khan Academy
to allow kids to start early,
if they know the material in kindergarten,
which most of us know,
but some of them might
even have a gap or two,
they can fill those in,
and then by the time they get
to that sixth grade material,
now they're ready to move ahead,
and you do both of those simultaneously.
- Exactly, and this is life changing.
I encourage every parent at home
with their child at home,
doing remote learning,
every teacher, maybe at least
offer this as extra credit
or something for the
rest of the school year,
to go back and do those
mastery challenges.
Quickly go through
those course challenges,
quickly go through lower grades.
And if it takes them a long time,
good, they needed to do that review.
If they do it quickly, okay, good,
now we know what they know.
And we can zero in on
which particular skills
they were struggling with.
But we all know, like high school,
kids think either they understand math,
because they really got it.
Or they think math is
just memorizing steps
because they really have
no clue what's going on,
and they eventually quit math,
'cause they think they just
don't have a math brain.
Well, Khan Academy can fix that,
and teach and show that every kid
can learn and master math,
thanks to growth mindset, especially.
- And I wanna talk a little
bit about school closures.
I'm curious about what were you doing,
but staying on the classroom model,
which I know there's a
lot of teachers listening,
and I'm sure many students and parents
would be curious about this as well.
You know, when I look at these
videos of your classroom,
they look highly interactive.
There's sometimes this stereotype
that when you use technology
or blended learning,
it can be this you know,
Vulcan or Borg reality where
it's just kids on computers.
What is, what do you see as your role
if the students are
practicing on Khan Academy,
they're getting that feedback,
and get a little micro
lesson when they need it.
What do you see is the role of,
as the teacher in the room?
- Right, the role of the
teacher or of the parent,
if they're doing this at
home with their child,
is to be actively engaged
monitoring progress,
helping the kids at point of need,
but after they have first
used the Khan videos
and the Khan hints,
or their classmates, or at home,
their older siblings or their parents.
Then the teachers role is to
jump in and help as needed,
but first I teach them
about agency and initiative,
and take ownership for their own learning.
Value there is the coach,
the support as needed.
But you see these kids,
this is normal, what you
see in the videos there.
They truly learn to learn
mostly on their own,
but they know when they
need me I'm right there.
- And that's a powerful
idea, cause obviously
you and I we both like mathematics,
we both think it's valuable to learn that.
But when you mention that notion of agency
that might be the most
important thing of all,
because then they're off to the races,
you've taught them to
fish, so to speak. (laughs)
It's one way,
to think about it.
- Absolutely.
- What is, how are you dealing,
You know, what's this,
I'm assuming your school has been closed
in Hesperian for several weeks.
I am curious, we haven't
talked about this.
What are, what's going
on in your district?
How are you dealing with
the school closures?
- Right, yeah, our school has,
our entire district has closed,
like I believe, all schools in California.
Well it worked out
beautifully, the transition,
my students took their Chromebooks home,
and they just keep going.
They just keep leveling
up their skill mastery,
where they were on each of those courses.
And we're gonna be
setting up remote learning
real soon here, now.
The kids are back from
spring break. (laughs)
So I gave them last week off,
but we're gonna be doing remote learning,
but they're basically on Khan Academy.
And I had kids yesterday
without even asking,
half the class going on Khan Academy,
without even being asked to,
and leveling up skills
and mastering new things,
even without me helping them.
But when they do need help,
absolutely, I'm there to help them.
- So the model that it
sounds like you're doing is,
you already had kids
working on Khan Academy
before the closures,
and when the closures
happen it was pretty easy,
obviously, to transition in some level,
'cause I guess device access
is an issue especially,
I could imagine, for a student population
with 100% free and reduced lunch,
but it sounds like y'all
had a great program
to send the Chromebooks home.
I am curious about internet access,
but what you're saying is these kids
are able to access it, keep working,
and it sounds like might also
be supplementing that with,
you know, video conferencing
to unblock them if necessary.
- Exactly and, yeah,
we do have most kids with
WiFi with internet access.
And the ones who don't,
then I supplement through
other paper pencils,
sort of materials, textbooks and stuff.
But the vast majority of
the kids can get it online,
because that was the expectation
at the start of the year.
And then those who couldn't,
well, I just found flexible ways
to help those who need help.
- And I am curious,
given that it sounds like your
kids are continuing to learn.
How are you thinking about the length
of the school closures?
It looks like it might,
it could very well go through
the end of the school year,
or what advice do you
have for other teachers,
parents for students,
of using this time as well as possible.
but then also the summer time?
- Absolutely, what a beautiful opportunity
to use Khan Academy, which is free,
and I'm not paid to say that.
If you agree,
why not use this time at home
catching up on all those skills,
go back to kindergarten,
do the course challenge on kindergarten.
See if you can finish it,
and master it all in an hour or two.
If not, then you probably needed
to review some skills,
even starting in third grade.
There's some very difficult skills
that a lot of high
schoolers never mastered.
Because they were not on
common core way back then.
Use this time to go
back and review skills,
fill in those gaps and make
math make sense for you,
so you can be a math champ
while you're at home,
doing remote learning.
And teachers and parents,
I recommend somehow motivating your kids,
your students, your children,
to use this mastery learning model.
This is absolutely life changing,
I've seen it three years in a row now,
four years after this school year.
These kids lives are absolutely changed,
they believe they can
learn and master math,
instead of being a failure at math,
like 90% of them were at lower grade.
They're now in junior high
in high school right now, my alumni,
and they are destroying
their math classes,
doing fantastic.
- Destroying in a good way.
I had a little internal giggle,
- In a good way (laughs)
- when you said
that we don't,
in a good way.
I had a little internal
giggle when you said
that we're not paying you.
Because obviously it's not-for-profit.
We will love it when people use us,
but our costs actually go up, (laughs)
which is why I'm always
asking folks for money.
- Sorry about that Sal.
- But no, we don't pay you.
and no, no, it's great,
this is why we exist.
And the, you know I've only met you,
I think we had our first
conversation only a few weeks ago,
but I've been really blown away.
You know, I've spoken and I've written
about a lot of these things in theory,
but you've taken it to
a whole other level,
in terms of practice.
So I think it's a good time,
we can open it up to some questions.
I see there's questions coming in.
So one question from YouTube,
Susana Dominguez asks,
are Mr. V students' continuing to work
on Khan at home,
now that we are home bound?
It sounds like that is the case.
In fact, it sounds like
you can't even stop them even
when they were off. (laughs)
- Correct, yeah what I do is,
I appraise them for those who,
every day I use the Khan activity,
overview data that Khan provides
for teachers and parents,
and I appraise the top 10 kids
who put in the most effort,
and also the top 10 kids who've leveled up
the most skills from the previous day.
And that really motivates them,
that positive reinforcement.
- Awesome, I have this other question
from Facebook Missy Muller says,
'Tim, have you had students that master
all K through fifth skills
before the year is up?
Do you have them move ahead of class
until later sixth or
seventh grade topics?'
- Right, as a sixth grade teacher,
every year I do have two or three kids
who master everything K through six.
So what I do is I unlock,
I call it unlock,
but I let them go ahead to pre-algebra,
and seventh grade and eighth grade math,
and I let that effort,
at credit in a balanced way.
You know, they already have A plus,
why not let them get an A plus plus?
And compared to junior high,
basically ready to teach
their seventh grade class,
and probably should push to head
to eighth grade math right away.
- Huh, that's incredible.
And let's see from Facebook,
Nikki Renee asked,
'If I set up second grade math,
my child has all the practice
quizzes and unit tests,
where do you go from there?
Do you have to achieve something
before it automatically moves you on?'
I could take a quick stab at that one.
Essentially yes, once your student
gets through, say 9% mastery
in second grade math through unit tests,
or course challenges
or mastery challenges,
then it would be a good idea to sit,
you know, 'cause I'm assuming
this is a younger student
you're talking about,
to then say, okay, it looks like
you've finished second grade.
And then you can set them a
goal to finish third grade,
and you can even pace that out.
One of the things we wanna
work on at Khan Academy,
we gave y'all the daily schedules
for different age groups.
But just as Tim was mentioning,
we have two months
through the school year,
then we have another three
months through the summer.
We wanna help parents and students,
and teachers to think about
goals that are reasonable
for different types of students,
as we go over the next five months.
But if your child finished
second grade, absolutely.
The system right now
won't say immediately go to third grade,
but you could sit next to them and say,
okay, let's start on third grade now.
Alright, so from Facebook,
Katie Kelly de Leon says,
'Hi Tim, I have hard time
navigating the website,
how do you assign the mastery model
that you teach to your students?'
- Okay, so, as a teacher,
you wanna make sure your students
are signed in under your
class in Khan Academy,
and then go under each course,
and you can set mastery
goals for your students.
And you can even set a date
deadline for your students.
And what that does,
is it signals to your kids that this is
what they should be working on.
And then it keeps track,
and you can then click
on that as a teacher
and follow their progress
as their percentage of mastery goes up.
So I hope that answers Katie's question.
- And that's good
feedback for all of us at,
actually both of y'all good feedback.
Katie, we are always trying
to improve the navigation.
So we actually liked the
constructive feedback.
We know it can get better.
And Tim's idea, I actually think
I would love to collaborate with you, Tim,
of ways to kind of publish goals at,
over the course of,
especially the next five months,
and I would love to do it consistent
the way you've done it,
'cause clearly, it's
been highly effective.
And I think that'll help a lot of
parents, students, and teachers.
So someone from YouTube,
Dal Lads said, I don't understand
how students take tests on Khan,
I've only seen videos.
So Dal, I think you might only
be on the YouTube channel,
I encourage you to go to khanacademy.org.
And if you go to,
you know, there's a menu that says
subjects at the top left,
if you go there,
especially if you look at
any of the ones in math
or the high school level sciences,
including biology,
chemistry, physics, Econ,
APCs principles, you will see
there's a view
where you have videos on the left.
And on the right, you have practice.
And if you click on that,
you'll see that as you get things right,
it has these, what we
call mastery mechanics.
So as you can see right here on the,
this is showing the various lessons,
but you can see these
mastery points available.
And then if you were to click
on one of those lessons,
then you'll be able to see
the various exercises you can do,
and get feedback.
And there's different levels,
you could do it at the skill level,
you can do it at a quiz level,
a unit test level,
a mastery challenge level
or a course challenge.
So I encourage you to go to
our site and try it all out.
All right, so other questions.
So some of these are a
little bit more general.
So from YouTube, Michael Azhar says,
'Sal, is there any way
I can improve my skills
using Khan Academy efficiently?'
So I have some ideas and
actually I'm curious Tim,
what you think about this.
So I think the best way to
efficiently use Khan Academy
is analogous to what
you just heard Tim say,
that he coaches his students to do.
Is start at a level that's maybe earlier
than your grade level,
unless you're very,
very confident in math.
But if you're not,
starting at an earlier grade level,
and I would start with
the course challenges,
because that samples
everything in the class,
and if you're able
to get through the course
challenges quite easily,
you can move on to the next grade level.
But if you're not able to
move through the course challenges easily,
the things that you got wrong,
you can then go to those units,
and then try to get
mastery in those units.
And I would say that's the most
efficient way to get mastery
at some of your foundational subjects,
as quickly as possible.
There's also ways you know,
if you're gonna learn anything,
whether it's math or piano
or improve your free throw,
it's all about consistency.
A lot of times we're all guilty of binge,
you know, studying or binge exercising
then we do nothing for a few weeks.
It's much better if you can
do a solid 30 minutes a day,
40 minutes a day,
if you're younger maybe 20 minutes a day.
You're going to see that if
you do that consistently,
that's going, you're gonna notice
you performing better,
you're looking at the world differently,
in a matter of a month or two.
Tim, anything to add to that?
- Yeah, I can't tell
you how powerful it is
to use the early math course to focus
on mastering the numbers sense concepts,
which is usually, research has shown,
is what holds kids and even adults back,
is grasping the true meaning of numbers,
and place value and fractions.
So early math,
and then the arithmetic
course on Khan Academy,
is a good summary review of everything,
basically K through maybe seventh grade,
those are great.
Turbo super fast reviews
to get through everything
and make sure you truly understand
what you need for junior
high and high school.
Then for older students,
the pre-algebra course really teaches
those basic skills of
working the key concepts
of algebraic manipulation.
- And one thing I'll add, you know,
both Tim and I have been talking a lot
about this importance of
really strong foundations.
But I've seen a lot of parents
have a little bit of anxiety
when it comes to math.
And I think this is also an opportunity,
now that we're all
socially distanced at home,
that if you do have some time,
and maybe even do it next to your child,
it's really great modeling for them.
For you to do what Tim has just mentioned,
go back to early learning,
if you know that material,
you'll get through it quite fast.
And if it takes you a
little bit more time,
it's because you needed it.
And I think that'll
change your perspective.
And it's very powerful
modeling for the students.
- Yeah, I have had a couple of parents
do that with their children.
And not only does it help the
parent, it encourages them.
This year, who was scared of fractions.
Her mom has been working
together with her,
on her own account of Khan,
and the two of them together are acing
our state practice tests
that we have been taking.
So it's been great,
parents, motivate your kids.
- That's awesome.
Let's see, there's a
question from Facebook,
Edward Swan says,
'Are there plans to match up
content with the UK system?'
So Edward right now,
we don't have that in theory,
that could happen in the future.
So it's definitely in
the realm of possibility.
I would say that obviously
the UK system is,
even in the US,
state to state can be
a little bit different.
It is different.
But especially in math,
if you master the
progression along the lines
that Tim has been talking about,
and make sure you have
a strong foundation,
you can go to pretty much any country.
And there might be a few standards
that are different here or there,
you will have a very strong foundation
and you'll feel yourself
very fluent in math.
And the same thing is also true
for things like biology, chemistry,
physics, if you're thinking about things
more at a high school
or early college level,
so I encourage you to do that.
But it is a good nudge first to think
about a mapping to things
like the UK system.
For other international folks out there,
We do have a Spanish version
of Khan Academy, es.khanacademy.org.
There is actually a
Brazilian-Portuguese version
of Khan Academy, which that team in Brazil
is actually mapping to the
Brazilian national Common Core.
We have a team in India that
is trying to do similar things.
There's also 40 translation
projects around the world,
done by volunteers on top of our platform,
to make Khan Academy available
in some of those other languages.
And they're, we're starting
to make the tools available
where they can curate and align them
better to their standards.
So we definitely do want
things like that to happen.
And so let's see other,
let's see from YouTube, Vishna Molly.
Oh I guess this is a testimonial.
'Hello, Sal, Khan Academy
saved me so much frustration,
so much clarity and teaching methods.'
Well thank you Vishna, we appreciate that.
And then next question I have is Elisa,
nice from Facebook is saying,
her sixth grader is doing well in math.
That's great, thanks to being
able to use Khan Academy.
We love hearing that,
that makes you know,
it energizes all of us
to hear news about how it's helping folks.
And let's see, other questions.
So actually, this is an interesting one.
And maybe both Tim and I can answer
this question from YouTube.
Kritath Bat says,
'Hey Sal, what is the best piece
of constructive criticism you've received
from a parent or a learner?'
So I think, you know all the time,
we got a little bit of
constructive criticism,
which I really appreciate,
a little earlier ago,
where I think it was a
parent or teacher was asking,
Hey, I'm having
a little bit difficulty
navigating the site.
I think that is one that
I've heard a few times.
You know, in the early
days of Khan Academy,
it was in many ways easier to navigate.
But now that there's
thousands of exercises,
and thousands of videos,
and you know, 30, 40 subjects,
it can be a little bit daunting
to understand how to navigate,
and especially cause there's
different modalities.
Teachers can assign unit
mastery, course mastery,
they can assign individual
skills for homework.
And so we recognize that we wanna be able
to simplify it as much as possible.
That's really constructive feedback.
I remember the early days of Khan Academy,
my penmanship was not so good. (laughs)
I definitely got some, (laughs)
constructive feedback about that.
And for sure, you know,
we get positive feedback.
And some people like the style
that I might instruct it,
some people might think I talked too slow
or too fast or, or whatever else.
So you know, it's always
great to get feedback
and think about how we
can get better at things.
Tim, well have you any
constructive feedback,
you'd like to highlight?
- Yeah, the high-stakes
constructive feedback
that every teacher gets every year,
is their state test students' results.
And it was very powerful
before I used Khan Academy,
just seeing wow, it's not working
using the old system.
I just can't get these
kids caught up in one year.
Even though I'm working so hard,
I gotta try something different.
So I tried this mastery learning model,
and that was the best
constructive feedback I ever got,
was realizing I gotta change,
I gotta do something different.
And kids ever since in my class
have been having their lives changed.
So that helped a lot.
Also I wanna point out,
I think your team is gonna post on this,
the show notes for this webinar.
A couple of webinars
recently did explaining
how to do mastery
learning in the classroom
or with your child at home.
So be sure to check that out as well.
- Yeah, no, that's great.
And actually one of those webinar videos
I've now included as a link
whenever I send an email to folks,
just so people see that because,
you know, it's one thing to
theoretically know about it.
But to hear from an incredible
practitioner like yourself,
and the type of results we're seeing
with a high-need population,
it's really inspiring.
So, we're all out of time.
These live streams go fast.
Tim, thank you so much for joining us.
I get inspired every time
- You're welcome.
- I chat with you.
And you know, for everyone
out there listening,
- I as well.
- Oh no, no, and maybe we'll
play some Monopoly,
I'm finding that,
that might be some
- Yeah.
- constructive criticism for me.
When I, when you crush me at Monopoly.
- I'll help your kids
learn how to beat you every time. (laughs)
- (laughs) Alright, but for all of y'all
who are listening,
thanks for joining, I know this is
a really, really hard time for the world.
But I think that's a little
bit of a silver lining
that we're all through this together.
And as I'm saying every week,
you know, this is a way to
connect with each other.
I also find a lot of connection
even though it's virtual and abstract,
through this live stream,
but it's a way to get us
through all of these school closures.
I'll throw out another reminder,
we are not-for-profit,
if you're in a position to do so,
please think about
donating to Khan Academy.
We need your help.
We're operating at a deficit right now.
But I look forward to seeing
y'all in the weeks ahead.
We're gonna bring more guests,
folks like Tim and others soon.
So with that, stay safe, stay healthy.
And I'll see you tomorrow.